que vous étiez content de rencontrer
Diego quand la dernière fois que j'ai vu
j'étais contente après finalement c'est
pas le top quoi c'est pas le top ça va
nickel ça démarre bien
ça alors si vous ne connaissez pas Diego
Diego il est Singa super moi je voilà je
l'adore mais c'est vrai qu'il a un petit
truc il peut enchaîner mytho sur mytho
euh voilà sauf qu'il était face à
l'inspectrice Cyrielle faites quoi dans
la vie je sais pas respectrice me faites
quoi
je suis placeuse
et toi Diego tu fais quoi pareil je suis
serveur et je travaille dans le médical
je rentre du matériel médical d'accord
très bien regarde parce que il y a quand
même aller sur les mythos là je vais sur
mes 25 ans
[Musique]
chez ce que je veux je
déjà j'ai 20 ans c'est vrai
donc ta date de naissance cousin
alors donc ça c'était le premier tour il
a triché sur son âge il a dit qu'il
avait 25 ans au lieu de 20 on passe au
deuxième mi-temps
jamais voulu te mentir
reste monteur c'est comme ça je vais
être honnête avec toi les week-ends
pourquoi tu m'as pas dit aussi parce que
je pensais que ça allait te faire peur
je me suis dit 20 ans je bosse un monde
de la nuit je chante une longue relation
je dis mais la meuf elle va jamais se
retourner sur moi elle va jamais me
faire confiance moi tu veux me faire
confiance tu es confiance avec le temps
c'est avec l'épreuve si ça pouvait
s'acheter je dirais t'en acheter du
respect
[Musique]
tu avais prévu de faire tous ces Mythos
parce qu'il y en a d'autres après non
c'est arrivé au tac au tac et en fait je
suis rentré dans un personnage et j'y
croyais moi-même à mes mytho c'est ça
j'étais pas serveur
et toi Cyrielle toi tu te capter mais
quand tu commences par en fait il était
pas crédible parce que tu peux pas me
dire que tu te couches à 20h le vendredi
que tu te lèves à 11h
c'est pas cohérent forcément au niveau
des heures de sommeil
[Rires]
et il commençais avec ça après il me
disait c'est mon anniversaire bientôt et
un jour je suis allé voir sur Facebook
parce que ça existe encore et puis tu
vois et j'ai vu ça date de naissance et
il a pas vingtaine quand donc je me suis
dit bon il se commence sur ça allez je
vais rien dire je vais voir si de
lui-même il va me le dire il me l'a
toujours pas dit même à l'heure actuelle
je pense que de lui-même il n'arrive pas
à se l'avouer qu'il a pas 25 ans
on s'en fout frérot on s'en fout et
alors ça aurait pu s'arrêter là mais
après là j'ai le métier il a lâché un
troisième mytho c'est pas le plus petit
regarde je vais te montrer un truc tu me
dis ce que tu en penses juste ok on est
d'accord
[Musique]
c'est qui ça
c'est ma cousine
c'est une blague c'est une grosse blague
[Musique]
allô allô
ma parole tu sais que j'ai le dérange
j'ai vraiment j'ai la haine de toi
[Applaudissements]
vous allez voir dans un instant
juste Cyrielle toi tu le kiffais avant
pourquoi c'est des petits Mythos
pourquoi
ça va
arrêter avec les gens comme arrêtez de
vous attacher à des détails
trois mois c'est rien nous étions pas
ensemble
on se dit il y a une base de respect à
respecter on est bien d'accord on parle
avec une personne pendant trois mois
pourquoi il va embrasse une autre fille
je connais alors ça alors là il a rien
d'embrassé là
s'il vous plaît non là franchement ça ça
se défend euh c'est une vidéo
il a pas vraiment embrassé alors je vais
vous dire en ce moment en plus il y a
plein de trucs c'est que maintenant
c'est vrai que non je crois que c'est un
prank non mais c'était pour apprendre à
lui agresser là voilà non non je te le
dis il y a rien après Diego pour moi
c'est le droit de la communication
je suis quand même en ayant fait trois
Mythos il a tenté de rattraper la
situation avec une proposition très
surprenante et là moi c'est là que j'ai
kiffé Diego et que là je me suis dit bah
Diego ça y est tu étais ça y est c'est
la famille c'est la famille
plein de choses j'ai envie que tu le
vois ma vraie vie je veux que tu
rencontres ma mère je veux que tu vois
mes grands-parents je veux que tu vois
mes frères et sœurs je crois que je t'ai
même pas dit j'avais des frères et soeur
aux autres ouais peut-être déjà un grand
frère j'ai un grand frère ça me fait
super plaisir je suis une rencontre j'ai
une petite sœur
pourquoi tu as plus envie continue
réfléchis toi ton côté je te remets
cette clé j'espère que tu vas faire le
bon choix
et puis je t'ai préparé une petite
surprise je sais que tu aimes bien joué
aux cartes donc j'ai ramené un petit jeu
de mots
et puis il fait le bon choix
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal ouais je crois moi je vais
te dire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
donc il peut pas mentir à moins que la
personne
n'est ni réseau sociaux ni la télé voilà
ok la personne toi est-ce que tu as
quelqu'un
ça fait depuis septembre
on a oui mais bon quand même non je la
sens pas doux je la sens pas doux non je
la sens pas de ouf
tu regrettes de ne pas avoir fait
d'histoire avec Diego je pense que si il
avait pas fait tout ça honnêtement
j'aurais pu parce que c'est une bonne
personne même si beaucoup c'est une
bonne personne moi aussi je l'aime bien
même si ment en fait de lui-même c'est
une bonne personne il y a une bonne
éducation ils sont très très gentils
mais j'adore hormis ces Mythos oui ça
aurait pu passer mais là c'est
impossible il faut apaiser les tensions
qu'est-ce qui te plaît chez lui de base
si tu sois mais en fait son ambition
dans la vie parce que il aimait beaucoup
le sport il aime tout ce que tout ce que
j'ai mais moi en fait c'était plaisir de
me retrouver
à ça moi si je peux me permettre Cyril
franchement je pense tu l'aimes bien
quand même j'ai l'impression que tu te
dis je vais peut-être passer à côté de
quelque chose non avant je l'aimais bien
dans une certaine façon et à l'heure
actuelle je l'apprécie en tant que
personne document quoi voilà mais pas
plus bonne chance à la prochaine mais
moi c'est pas pour
je vais te dire la vérité
moi je suis pas pour que tu arrêtes euh
moi je te le dis je suis voilà mon ami
voilà je te dis bon moi voilà je suis
pas pour que tu arrêtes je ne suis pas
pour donc pour moi le problème c'est que
je voulais pas enfin mentir ça me
dérange pas forcément quand même
une fille donc là là je j'envoie
demi-tour à gogo bien sûr mais quand je
parle en fait avec Cyrielle ben je suis
rentré dans un truc où après on a parlé
sérieusement je me suis attaché à elle
là je peux plus faire et là tu as envie
d'être ami avec elle ou ça te saoule non
je peux être ami avec elle ça me dérange
pas et après peut-être alors je
t'explique peut-être ça se termine avec
tu as des ex amis aussi et Cyril je sens
quand même que tu vas te mettre un peu
comme on dit en stand by quoi tu peux
après voilà si ça se termine avec son
mec ça peut peut-être le faire on verra
bien pour l'instant elle est en cours
même si c'était célibataire
en fait une personne elle va mentir une
fois elle va connaître la faille et en
fait elle va tout le temps savoir quoi
dire très bien mais non mais c'est pas
méchant peut-être dans 10 ans sans doute
sans contrarier tu as l'air déçu ça veut
dire qu'il y a encore
je te sens quand même ouais parce que
sinon je l'aime beaucoup
tu serais pas énervé comme ça
tu as fait quelque chose là quand on est
arrivé tout à l'heure oui ça m'a fait
quelque chose
j'étais en fait
c'était plus déçu parce que je me suis
dit on aurait pu si tu es déçu
c'était des jeux j'ai l'impression allez
j'ai rien contre ton Dieu
mais je sens les choses moi l'amour je
le sens j'ai l'amour il vient dans dans
mon nez et ben je te le dis voilà je te
le dis je sens que tu aimes bien tu
l'aimes bien quand même donc
je te dis j'ai l'impression que ton mec
est un pansement
ça tu penses pas ouais si si je pense
[Applaudissements]